I want to start with congrats
um it uh it's really cool that you guys
got to make a big Studio Movie oh thank
you yeah yeah it was a really fun one to
make a million questions for you guys
the first is probably the most important
uh I give credit to anyone who's going
to open a movie theater and you guys are
opening a movie theater in Davenport
which is awesome so I just have to for
people that live in that area or
whatever like how did that happen that
you're opening a movie theater well
thanks thanks for bringing that up it's
it's a passion project of ours I mean
the theater going experience to us is is
sacred and Davenport Iowa where we're
from is a very unlikely place but that's
what kind of makes makes it magical
um it's it's a place where uh early on
way back when one of the first 16
millimeter film cameras was starting to
get developed But ultimately it it lost
out by other competition and it's it's
the Heartland and it's it's a place that
we want to reinvigorate the cinema going
experience I feel like it's been kind of
ruined by the way that multiplexes um
sometimes don't actually like pay
attention to projection or sound or what
the programming is and so we're building
this it's got two screens it's got a
rooftop screen and the plan is outside
of doing first run theaters do Repertory
screenings do cult screenings do
community screenings
um not dissimilar to what Tarantino is
doing with the new Beverly but also make
it a hub for film going activity Bring
Back special guests you know if the
movie theater were open now we'd be
screening 65 there and you know bring
driver back or Sam Raimi and just just
make sure that Cinema stays relevant
from a community standpoint that we're
not all stuck inside our homes you know
watching things on streaming exclusively
I saw the artwork of what the theater is
going to look like in the upstairs with
the outdoor thing uh I'm just saying uh
uh I I appreciate you guys doing this
and I hope it's a you know obviously
very successful whole business oh thanks
for saying thank you thank you if you
guys could get the financing to make
anything you want uh what would you make
and why
financing I mean it's funny because I
feel like we're coming off the heels of
something for the longest time that we
wanted to make like doing a dinosaur
movie I think the one place we haven't
made and this is going to feel somewhat
generic but it's like doing a space
movie like a pure space
film
um you know whether that takes place on
on different planets or not
one franchise that I know we would have
loved to do but I feel like it just
keeps getting remade and remade is
Resident Evil I feel like every time we
want to raise our hands for the Resident
Evil movie someone has just been rehired
to do like the the fifth remake of it
and our whole thing like Resident Evil
is a is a video game that Brian and I
played when we were we were growing up
back in Iowa's kids and it was so
cinematic because you're on these long
tracking shots that were suspenseful and
you never knew what was around the
corner and we had always wanted to do a
Resident Evil movie that was like
ostensibly a winner as if like the
marriage of George Romero meets Gus Van
Sant and with his death Trilogy of like
Jerry and elephant and last days and use
like style to really inherently create
suspense so I don't know that's one on
the bucket list I don't know we'll ever
see the light of day because sometimes I
ask that question and people are like
stumped and other times people have
ideas and they're like it I'll just
pitch it right now yeah you know
absolutely Resident Evil
um so uh what do you guys wish you knew
or could tell yourself on the first day
of filming 65 like something that you
learned in the edit or during the shoot
that you wish you had known these are
great questions like they're they're
they're keeping us on our toes I mean I
like I
I would say like enjoy the process like
the the problem is like filmmaking
sometimes is like 16 hour days and and
you're you're working six days a week
sometimes seven days a week and it's
just it's a really physically
challenging and mentally challenging but
to enjoy the process of like making a
dinosaur film I think that that is
always the the thing that we were trying
to remember but maybe not not
remembering clear enough yeah there were
a few like there were a few moments
throughout shooting where where we were
like oh yeah this is a dinosaur movie
like there's uh one of the days we had
um uh we we got a group of uh Cirque du
Soleil uh performers to dress up in
these kind of giant dinosaur suits and
perform as dinosaurs and to have like
those practically and physically on set
was like a great reminder like oh how
like how lucky are we to to be able to
live out our kind of ten-year-old dreams
on film but um but yeah it was a it was
a tough shoot it was a tough shoot
because we shot this thing in 40 days we
it's all practical locations in a world
where pretty much every movie is shot on
a VR Sound Stage at this point
um you know to be able to go to to
waterfalls and hike up a mountain to
find a particular Forest that's never
been put on film before it was
um challenging and
um and I agree with Scott it would be
nice to go back and and try to enjoy the
ride a little bit one of the things
listen you guys made this you didn't
have Marvel money to make this movie and
I know how movies are made and how you
know you have to give up certain things
because you have your schedule and your
budget so was there anything that you
were really sad that you had written
that you loved that you just didn't have
the time or money to actually put in the
movie and how did you sort of solve that
problem or you know fix it yeah I mean I
think there's you know there's set
pieces that you know by virtue of having
to shoot like for 40 days like you just
don't have all the time in the world to
do that there's um sequences that are
like precursors on on the spaceship like
with Mills so there's there's things
from a story standpoint that you write
it all down but then inevitably the
filmmaking process condenses it and you
have to find ways to convey the story in
other ways but that's the challenge that
I feel like we've been facing since we
were 11 years old like making movies in
our own backyard like we need to have a
giant explosion happen here but we can't
do pyrotechnics we're you know 12 years
old and so we have to find ways to like
use power of suggestion and that has
never left us you know this movie
um knowing we've got a budget to do you
know visual effects dinosaurs and some
practical dinosaurs but you can't spend
you know 100 170 million dollars
achieving all that you have to start
thinking about okay sound design or we
see the shadows of something and it's
kind of a fun creative exercise it can
be maddening at times because you're
really challenging yourself from a
career native standpoint But ultimately
like that's that's kind of what we've
been doing since we were kids and it was
kind of the the appeal the Allure of
this movie for us frankly was taking a
high concept pulpy B movie premise and
putting it on a large canvas but then
executing it with kind of um almost a
minimalist uh intimate approach with the
characters like we kind of joked like
it's almost like uh the movie features
our love of Roland numeric uh disaster
movies but also Terence Malik like it's
a it's a hybrid of that and I think that
was part of the appeal for us and why we
were grateful to have a a wonderful
performer like Adam Driver because every
day we're not talking about
um necessarily dinosaurs and which
dinosaurs are creeping up we're kind of
talking about the um simmering uh
emotional weight that his character is
carrying and how that comes out without
dialogue that was the fun uh how did you
guys decide on Salvatore I think that's
how you pronounce his name Salvatore how
did you decide on him as your DP and
talk a little bit about crafting uh some
of the specific shots with him because
you have some cool shots in the movie
one's in the trailer with the T-Rex or
right behind the water you know and and
you know and the thing is as you said
you were 40 days you can't spend all day
trying to make one shot perfect yeah
well one thing that was fascinating
about Sal is um the variety of films
that he shot you know from Everest which
they actually shot at on parts of the of
Mount Everest and there was a
physicality that he brought and then he
also has shot you know more intimate
character-driven things like frost Nixon
and I think he just seemed like he would
have the tenacity the energy and then
the creative Spirit
um to come on board a film like this
that was shot you know quite frequently
on practical locations
he also has a ability to innovate and
design so for instance there's there's a
scene where our characters are sleeping
in the mouth of a cave
um before a T-Rex comes up behind them
and we had to build a custom track that
had to be totally engineered and built
from scratch and we would storyboard
um almost every single frame of this
movie to figure out how do we achieve
these different visual designs and he
would be right there next to us doing
the math but also having the creative
collaboration and conversation of how do
we best achieve this how are we getting
inside the characters if the shot is
more about the internal or if it's about
the external threat so it's a constant
like check-in with him but he was a
dream collaborator for us I'm curious uh
listen I like talking about the editing
process because it's where it all comes
together so how did the film change in
ways you didn't expect in the editing
room I'll start with that well the movie
evolved a lot in post just the nature of
the movie which is a very quiet movie
not a lot of dialogue a lot of
suggestion and internal emotion in order
to Telegraph the story so anytime you
know it was a it was a fussy movie the
right it had to be the right piece of
music it had to be the right sound
effect or sound design in order for any
given scene to even work
um and so it was a constant
um Evolution and pressure test and
sampling and trying different stuff
different cuts different different edits
the way certain shots would cut together
it was um it was finicky because there's
no and this was uh you know our this is
the challenge we we put on ourselves
um and and Adam put on us as well which
is how do we do this with those few
lines of dialogue as possible if we if
we do the film The Way We wanted it to
you should be able to press the mute
button and still follow the story that
was that was the kind of initial
challenge so it was a very as you can
imagine a very precious kind of finicky
um process success to get the story to
come out talk a little bit about I
always ask about deleted scenes did you
end up with a lot on The Cutting Room
floor or no there's I mean there's a few
scenes
um that that uh didn't make the cut and
we'll we'll probably be featuring them
on on something like the home video
releases I mean there's certain
sequences between like Adam and Ariana
where it's like a quiet moment amidst
like a threat and it was always like
that gut check of do they bond too early
or do you need to kind of withdraw the
threat in this moment and just let it be
about like quietness or doesn't need to
be the opposite so it's that inevitable
thing where we can write all the scenes
in the world but ultimately like the the
movie and the editing process is really
informing us of what what the movie
actually needs and what we can shut away
before I run out of time with you uh I'm
obviously a fan of you do other things
besides direct this movie uh what are
you excited for fans to see in boogeyman
boogeyman is
um wow we're uh something we were really
proud of it's uh our favorite Stephen
King piece of writing which is absurd
because he's done so much miraculous
writing but we just always loved this
the short story The Boogeyman it always
creeped us out and it's so
um simple and and clean and and
terrifying and um to be able to play in
that sandbox was uh quite the dream Rob
Savage did a great job and um I think
it's gonna be I think it's gonna be fun
for audiences to see I I hope it's
another reason
um for people to come out to the
theaters and we were really
uh really moved by 20th's decision to
take it as it was ostensibly
um going to be a Hulu release and they
kind of um are reinvesting in the
ecosystem of theaters which is so
important to us that's the thing that I
actually wanted to touch on because I
had hoped with prey which Dan did that
that would get a theatrical release but
the contracts and everything I mean for
people who don't realize maybe you can
explain it it's a big deal to take what
contracts are for Hulu and saying oh
let's do it in theaters yeah our
understanding was with prey it was
almost a contractual impossibility for
that movie to come out in theaters
because it it would get tied up in other
streaming services if it played in
theaters and so were Boogeyman was
fortunate that it wasn't stuck in like
the the 2022 pipeline or else it would
have been strictly streaming it's coming
out in 2023 this summer
um which allowed it to kind of finagle
out of those contractual obligations but
again we wrote the film initially for
20th Century Fox when Fox was still
around and it was a studio film and so
for it to go to streaming but now come
back to uh to theatrical is is
incredibly inspiring to us
um we feel like there's been a turn now
after the last three years of like a
really weird theatrical landscape that
hopefully will find a new normal where
yes streaming is not going anywhere but
there will be a certain type of movie or
a certain expectation of of the
theatrical uh movie going process that
that inspires us because that's that's
what we fell in love with as kids and
there's nothing like seeing a movie in a
movie theater it's cliche but true
gentlemen I really do hope this is a
huge hit for you guys and uh thank you
for giving me your time oh of course
thank you